funny thing is relationships start
nowadays non-monogamous because you you
guys have heard me interview woman after
woman on the show most women will admit
to being in a situationship what is that
it's non-monogamy probably with the top
20 percent of men whether we want to
admit it's a thing women have had the
most sexual selection in the last
hundred years so in the past hundred
years women have had more mate selection
than we have ever had in history
typically your family would pick out
your husband your dad would pick out
your husband your brothers would help
you find a husband now women have
complete control and autonomy and it's
actually interesting because the more
control that women have had the more
mate selection women have had the more
women have picked non-monogamy and